I'm Laura Ingram this is Ingram angle
from Washington tonight my angle in
moments but first they wanted today to
be all about former president Trump's
Miami arraignment now the coverage it
was kind of reminiscent of OJ and the
white Bronco I want to take you to these
pictures now as we can see that appears
to be president Trump who just entered
that vehicle that we're seeing president
Trump in that SUV former president Trump
in that SUV you're looking right there
at the SUV we'll wait and see what
happens over the next minute or so see
if we can tell who's getting out there's
Donald J Trump coming out of uh the car
there the SUV going up the steps
and did you know that this was extremely
historic
tomorrow a remarkable moment in U.S
history will unfold the first ever
arraignment of a former president in
federal court historic and unprecedented
we've never seen a former president sit
in federal court at a defendant's table
soon he will take off for Florida and
for history
and of course a day like this would not
be complete without disgraced former FBI
officials passing judgment on their
favorite Target
our system is not based on you know we
don't play by organized crime rules it's
not you take out one of my guys I take
out one of your guys it's all equal I
think what we know about Donald Trump is
his approach to business his approach to
politics his approach to pers
interpersonal relations it is a constant
pursuit of Advantage my guess and it's
speculation is that he saw in this
material information that might be
useful to him at some point in the
future where's the disclaimer you're
listening to a liar when he comes on but
then a few hours ago Republican senator
Chuck Grassley stepped onto the senate
floor he completely upended official
Washington from what I've been told by
folks who've reviewed it at the foreign
National who allegedly bribed Joe and
Hunter Biden allegedly has audio
recordings of his conversation with them
17.
such recordings 15 audio recordings of
phone calls between him and Hunter Biden
according to the 10 23
the foreign National possesses two audio
recordings of phone calls between him
and then Vice President Joe Biden
these recordings were allegedly kept as
a sort of insurance policy for the
foreign National in case that he got
into a tight spot okay Grassley hasn't
heard the tapes himself but he's not a
guy known to reach for hyperbole at the
drop of a hat so these allegations have
to be taken very seriously joining us
now is house Judiciary Committee chair
Jim Jordan house oversight Committee
Member Byron Donald and Molly Hemingway
editor-in-chief of the Federalist Fox
News contributor Congressman Donald said
start with you
um since you've viewed the document that
Grassley is actually referencing there
is there anything that he said in those
comments on the senate floor that
doesn't kind of pan out from what you've
seen
Lord good to be with you look I think
everything that Senator Grassley says
does pan out because the document does
state that the barisma executive
actually has receipts that's all it says
that he has information but you just
don't know what the information is and
then the other piece that definitely
pans out is that they move the money
through through several accounts that
would take investigators 10 years to
find that is the modus operandi of the
Biden family whether whether the money
comes from China Romania and now it's
looking like Ukraine they move it
through all these llc's through all of
these accounts and it ends up in the
hands of the family and by the way I
will add this Joe Biden likes to say
that the rich need to pay their fair
share well Hey Joe did you pay your
taxes on that five mil I don't think you
did
Molly let's go to you on this I mean
this is amazing it's a case of incurious
journalists who are covering Trump's
every movement again like it's you know
in 1994 and it's OJ you know with with
Kato Kaelin waiting in the wing
somewhere and yet we have bank accounts
we have someone like Grassley making uh
these claims based on what he
understands of this record and yet
where's ABC NBC where's the coverage
well and you really have two big stories
that the media should be looking into
one is yes the Biden family business
where we learned today from Senator
Grassley that the foreign National had
17 recordings two involving the vice
president or claim to have those and we
also heard from that uh that Senator
Grassley said that Joe Biden was
involved in getting Hunter Biden on the
barisma board both of those are
explosive things but what's also
explosive is what Senator Grassley is
really focusing on which is the FBI did
not do a good job of receiving this
information and investigating it they
began to investigate it and then when it
looked bad for the Biden family they did
everything in their power to hide it and
keep it from being fully investigated
that is such a scandal given that what
we're talking about is the FBI meddling
once again in a presidential election on
behalf of a preferred candidate and
against the one that they oppose and all
of this of course is happening as they
are literally trying to imprison their
top political opponent
Jordan
making this fanciful claim that you
can't draw any equivalence between Biden
and Trump's cases watch this
we've been kind of living in this world
throughout the course of any
investigation a former president Trump
and says what about the bidens is that a
fair analog
I don't think we are talking about an
Apples to Apples comparison here so no
it's not a fair analog in that nobody in
these cases has been stashing hundreds
of documents with classified markings in
a bathroom
Congressman Jordan your response to that
well when you got three people who got
classified document concerns and you
know supposedly mishandled Clinton Biden
and and president Trump and only one
gets indicted how is that Justice how is
that equal application of the law
Americans have common sense they see
this double standard uh that that exists
for republicans and conservatives and
for president Trump for goodness sake
but I can't get past the irony Laura the
irony that I remember when Jim Comey
said I hope there are tapes when he's
talking about him and now looks like we
have tapes for goodness sake that this
guy kept the other thing about that
document I read that document last week
too the section Byron was referencing
about this foreign National who was an
executive at barisma he also says in
that section we what he tells the
competition human Source we don't need
anything there's nothing to worry about
because we have so many bank accounts
it'll take forever for them to figure it
out and he also says we never paid the
big guy directly so now we know this is
the second person to use that term he
uses that term before we knew about the
first guy James gillyard a business
associate of Hunter Biden when we
learned about that in October 2020 this
document was put together in August of
2020. so now we got both sides of the
equation using the same term the big guy
and if the big guy's not Joe Biden
somebody needs to explain to me who it
is so that's that's the part of them
that from the document I took away is
wow that is the most compelling that
evidence I think that shows how this is
connected to the president of the United
States this is why this document in the
end does need to be made public so the
whole country gets to see it all of it
has to be Declassified especially
Congressman Donald since we're we're
fighting a proxy war in Ukraine right
now we also and I'm going to get to this
my angle we also have serious concerns
about whether we're able to take on
China now given our depletion of
Munitions we're going to get into that
in a moment so we have these big
geopolitical challenges and perhaps
money going from two big geopolitical
forces to the Biden family I mean this
this is I mean and we're talking about
documents in a bathroom I'm not saying
those aren't important but come on we
got money from foreign countries
you're absolutely right one quick thing
Laura this F this FBI doc 1023 is not a
classified document they made us review
it in the skiff but that document is not
classified that's number one number two
I find it highly ironic that none of
this ever sees the light of day with any
of the members of the press but the
second they get a transcript of an audio
recording it is now leaked to the entire
press I thought that leaking information
in a criminal investigation was against
the law that's what I heard and long
time ago I thought that's illegal as
well but here's the last Point you're
making a key point the president and the
president's family and I stress the
president and the president's family
have been shaken down foreign companies
and foreign countries for a long time
don't tell me that Joe Biden is not
compromised by the fact that his family
has gotten millions and millions of
dollars through all these dummy shell
corporations that they set up in his
last year and a half as vice president
they set it up on purpose for this exact
thing and I think it's time that a
special counsel is brought forward to
investigate this the same way they have
this zealous uh prosecution of President
Trump yeah Molly just to continue on
with that the National Security
implications of a money Trail through
various shell corporations and accounts
that make their way to Biden Family Inc
is that not significant if this all pans
out as we think it will and I think it
will
again we're talking what's more
important here I'm not saying classified
documents and the way they're stored
isn't important I actually think it is
important but what's more important here
for the future of America the bathroom
documents or what hap what's happening
with China and Ukraine and I think
people remember that we had years of
conspiracy theories about the previous
president supposedly being a victim of
compromat that Russian that Russia had
against him here you have an actual
allegation from a credible whistleblower
saying that a foreign National has tapes
of compromise and the media are like
gosh I don't really think there's
anything here and I'm glad that
representative Donald mentioned that
this is not even a classified document
but Christopher Ray and the FBI are
hiding it from the American people
because it's embarrassing to the FBI
that they did not investigate it and
Senator Grassley made a very good point
today he said this is the FBI that is
leaking to the New York Times classified
information every day but they won't
reveal an unclassified document to the
American people and so yes you care
about classified information a lot of
Americans have been caring about
classified information as everybody in
the FBI was leaking like a sieve to The
Washington Post in New York Times to Gin
up fake controversies but you don't hear
the media saying that they think the
Espionage Act should be used against
them or the people that they were
working with to undermine the country so
we're seeing a lot of problems all
across the board and Congressman Jordan
I know people watching are thinking we
keep hearing these complaints all the
time about the FBI I've been hearing
this for years in the Intel agencies
when are Republicans going to use the
power of the purse and say we're done if
you hear some of the presidential
candidates Rob Swami obviously Trump and
DeSantis they all want to do something
here but now it's up to you all yeah it
sure is we will use the Appropriations
process the first appropriation bill is
going to pass next week out of the house
and then we have several others we have
to use the power of the purse and
frankly what we also have to do visor
reauthorization is up this year we have
to fundamentally change fisa get the FBI
out of that program all together we're
sick of the abuse that takes place there
so we have to do that but in the end
Laura the only thing that's going to
change is when we have somebody new in
the White House who put someone in
charge of the justice department that
will get rid of all this we can do
everything we can from from the
legislative branch and we're going to do
that and we're going to change fisa but
in the end you have to have an executive
who says we will no longer have a
justice department that targets we the
people that targets the American citizen
that is the only thing that's going to
fix it the Press isn't going to cover it
we have to do it that way and that's why
elections are important yeah defund a
new president both how about a one-two
punch panel great to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else